[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up
powering britain the government's plan
for energy supply which could reshape
the way we all live our lives
a political row behind the scenes as the
treasury blocked spending on helping
households insulate their homes
sanctions stepped up against russian
fossil fuels what impact will that have
on europe
and the ukrainian scientists collecting
data in antarctica as war rages at home
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world hear from
the people being hit hardest by those
changes and report on the race for
solutions
how to power britain the quest to tackle
net zero emissions rocketing energy
bills and the war in ukraine all have
forced the government to rethink the way
the country is run and the energy
sources that we use
the energy security strategy was delayed
but is now due to be published tomorrow
so what will be in the plan well this is
what we know the prime minister has made
it clear he wants a quarter of the
country's electricity to be nuclear
powered by 2050. now that's up from
about 16
in 2020.
the government is also a big supporter
of offshore wind now there's currently a
40 gigawatt target by 2030 and that's
likely to increase
more solar power is expected to be part
of the plan with suggestions of tax
incentives and grants for local projects
the strategy will also include the
doubling of hydrogen production a
cleaner alternative to gas to power
industry as well as heavy transport
what we're not so sure about is the role
of onshore wind now there's debate over
whether planning regulations should be
relaxed to allow for it to play a bigger
role and we should get more clarity on
whether north sea oil and gas resources
are to be exploited further here's our
business correspondent paul kelsey
the government's energy security
strategy will be an attempt to do three
things to deliver energy security to hit
net zero targets and to try in the
medium term at least to bring down
consumer costs and it's going to do that
with a mixture of technologies some new
fossil fuels oil and gas exploration in
the north sea a commitment to new
nuclear power stations really
significant growth in that sector and
also really new exciting technologies
like hydrogen now this is an
electrolyzer at the heart of green
hydrogen technology it uses these
membranes to drive power into water
which is then split into hydrogen
and oxygen and it uses renewable energy
to do it that's why it's called green
hydrogen because there's no carbon burnt
empowering
the electrolyzer and there's no carbon
burnt for the emission of hydrogen now
these sit inside one of these this is an
industrial electrolyzer made here this
is the biggest factory in the world
making these we're in sheffield now this
has a capacity of two megawatts we
understand the government's target is
going to be five
gigawatts of green hydrogen so that's
two and a half thousand of these now
they say they can make these here the
target for the uk perhaps in that
context is quite modest but there's a
global race for hydrogen it's versatile
not only can it replace the gray
hydrogen the dirty hydrogen used in
industrial processes like fuel refining
and fertilizer it can also perhaps drive
domestic heating vehicles as well so
this is an exciting new tech what's less
clear from the government is what
they're going to do about the tricky
issue of that north sea oil and gas
which is going to come under question
and criticism for burning fossil fuels
also a big question about what to do
about onshore wind we know there'll be a
commitment to offshore wind farms what
about onshore where there's great
concern in the conservative party about
its unpopularity at a local level
effectively planning gets in the way at
the moment look at what public attitudes
say about onshore wind if people know
they're going to get cheap power they
don't mind seeing a wind turbine in
their back garden truth is to deliver
energy security genuinely for the uk and
net zero it's gonna need all of these
technologies massively increased in the
coming years
the prime minister has said there's a
limit to how much taxpayers money can be
used to help people with rocketing
energy bills and sky news understands
the treasury has blocked an expansion of
the funding for home improvement
programs which could reduce demand for
gas as well as reduce costs well skies
chief political correspondent john craig
joins me now so john what more are you
hearing about this
well this is the latest spat involving
the chancellor and either downing street
or the business department now the
business department ahead of the prime
minister's big energy blueprint which is
being unveiled tomorrow wanted to extend
help for people from poorer household to
insulate their homes better to save
money on their bills the idea was that
they wanted an expansion of something
called the energy company obligation eco
scheme that uses money raised from an
energy levy a levy on energy bills to
pay for home efficiency uh improvements
however the chancellor took the view now
we spent enough on that sort of thing
and what the government has told sky
news is that uh that they're investing
over three billion pounds in this
parliament to help improve energy
efficiency in over half a million
low-income households delivering an
average saving of 300 pounds a year on
people's bills and clearly the
chancellor wants to stick to his
spending plans so that will not feature
in the big energy plan tomorrow the pm
was talking today he was actually
visiting a hospital in welling garden
city in hertfordshire he talked about
short-term measures help for people with
their bills now and that's when he said
look there's a limit to what we can do
but then he went on to talk about the
long term now over the past couple of
weeks he's used this phrase
talking about going to bet big on
nuclear so we can expect a big expansion
of nuclear power a dash for nuclear if
you like at the weekend quasi-cuatang
the business secretary was talking about
six or seven new nuclear power stations
so uh this is likely to be the
centerpiece of uh what the
prime minister's talking about tomorrow
as for the short-term problem of rising
bills well labour as we know wants a
windfall tax the liberal democrats who
today launched their local government
local elections campaign were talking
and calling for a uh a cut in vat at the
top rate from 20 to 17 and a half
percent for a year that according to the
lib dems would save people 600 pounds a
year
john thank you
let's get some of the day's other
climate news now and mps say the uk
should publish regular carbon emissions
data alongside economic growth
statistics in order to measure the
country's prosperity members of the
environmental audit committee have
written to the chancellor rishi sunak
warning the current measure of gdp
doesn't take environmental impact into
account the committee says the uk must
pull out all the stops to meet climate
change goals and that including progress
towards net zero targets would give a
more accurate assessment of the state of
the economy and society
power cuts from extreme weather in the
united states have doubled in the last
20 years according to analysis of u.s
government data by the associated press
wildfires and hurricanes made more
frequent by climate change are among
extreme weather events that are causing
more frequent and longer power cuts
across 40 u.s states
it also means power grid maintenance is
skyrocketing and customers are paying
more for electricity
monkfish from the north sea some crabs
and lobsters are amongst 14 new species
to join the marine conservation
society's fish to avoid the charity says
it's due to concerns about whales
getting caught in fishing gear and
overfishing
monkfish from the north sea and west of
scotland have declined to their lowest
level since 2013.
one of the rarest amphibians in the
world is now thriving after being
reintroduced to the uk last year the
northern pool frog's existence in the uk
was only discovered after it was
declared extinct in 1995.
the amphibian and reptile conservation
trust raised tadpoles in special tanks
before releasing 500 ponds in norfolk in
july
ikea's owner inca group has bought nine
solar power farms across germany and
spain
for 373 million dollars the furniture
giant says the sites will have a
combined capacity of 440 megawatts of
electricity in a statement the company
said it expects the new projects to
produce enough power to supply all ikea
stores and warehouses in germany and
spain
now the uk will end all imports of
russian coal and oil by the end of this
year the announcement is part of
coordinated western sanctions against
the kremlin in response to russia's
invasion of ukraine the eu has banned
russian coal worth several several
billion dollars a year and says it plans
to go further
these sanctions will not be our last
sanctions as i said already yesterday
yes we've now banned coal but now we
have to look into oil and we'll have to
look into the revenues that russia gets
from the fossil fuels and we really have
to make an effort for example to take a
share to the escrow
to an escrow banking system so that we
will really limit the source of revenues
from russia from
from fossil fuels it has to be an end
with that and this is the next step we
have to take together
while european countries are concerned
about the impact on their economies that
these sanctions will have it's having
the side effect of accelerating longer
term plans to move from fossil fuels to
renewables
germany heavily dependent on russian gas
announced plans today to have 80 percent
of their power grid from green energy up
from a previous target of 65 percent
jesus christ this package will lead to a
significant increase in renewable energy
combined with the other measures that we
are taking we believe that we are taking
an important step today to achieve
climate protection goals but also the
energy and security policy goals that
germany has to ensure
now the war in ukraine has
understandably taken precedence in many
people's minds over the climate crisis
especially you think for ukrainians but
a team of scientists had left for a
crucial antarctic mission before the
invasion began
thomas moore has been speaking to one
member of that team
glory to ukraine they shout proud to fly
their flag ten thousand miles away in
antarctica but desperately worried what
might happen to those left behind in the
war
these climate scientists and their
support crew are on their way to the
country's research base on the continent
where many will stay for the next year
angelica is a meteorologist
say hi
connection with the outside world from
so far south is poor at best just before
our flight
i heard the whistle of missiles and
battling intercept fighters and bombs
and that was very very hard to make a
decision to leave my country and come
here sometimes in the people when no one
sees
i can little bit cry
when you're far away and you know that
your family is in a
country with war
that's a real
it's really
my fault
but for the sake of science it was vital
the polar mission continued the
ukrainian base once run by british
antarctic survey is where the ozone hole
was first discovered
it's very valuable we can't lose them
because it would help the world
to know when and how the ozone
hole
occurs
i'm really proud of everyone and they
didn't give up
about this
antarctic research and
they continue to hold on the team swaps
whatever news they can glean from back
home and there is always the scenery to
distract them
unfortunately we haven't seen whales yet
but i think
we would
the purity of snow
it also just cleansed our hearts from
all the tears and all their thoughts
in ukraine they are seen as heroes
flying the flag on the only continent
where there has never been a war and
making sure their contribution to
climate science is not forgotten thomas
more sky news
do stay with us coming up i'll be joined
by former energy secretary amber rad and
the director of union for justice majeed
majeed and we'll be discussing energy
security does the government have the
right priorities and what impact will
sanctions on russia have on europe
[Music]
it was um one of the most one of the
most difficult things i've ever tried to
attempt um starting in the water around
4 am in the pitch dark
um jellyfish stings and putting on a lot
of weight because the biggest risk of
death is hypothermia
but like um also being stung by
jellyfish around my eyes um so you have
a grueling 14 hours 44 minutes the
reason i did it was for charity and i've
always kind of tried to give back as
much as i can and throughout my whole
life i feel feel like i've been a very
privileged situation with very
supportive family around me
um so the reason why i did it was and
there was actually a charity out in
india that i wanted to support
the children um sadly were sold by their
own parents in the sex slave industry
um and seeing those detrimental effects
um on those children growing up being
studying child psychology and
at university i understood those those
those kind of former years are so
important and just seeing them witness
and being kind of kind of exposed to
such awful things at a young age i knew
like right i've got to do something to
support them and kind of get them out of
that system and provide themselves kind
of a safe haven so that was the real
reason why i decided okay i've got to
come back and do something really big so
we can start talking about these really
tough uh issues that are happening still
in the 21st century now my aim is kind
of going out and spreading that message
i feel like i've kind of gone out and
kind of worked on my own mindset and
understood the importance of giving back
and which is why now i've written a
children's book and where all of like
kind of my story and examples of having
that i can attitude and the positive and
positive rewards of kind of giving back
is in a book and with that kind of
the messages i want i've shown is the
resilience and i think that's kind of
everyone has had that resilience and
that positive mindset to achieve
anything that they want in life
i'm now kind of going out and talking at
schools and doing some inspirational
kind of hoping to inspire the next
generation i want to make a splash in
the next generation
and kind of have that ripple effect so
that children will go out and hopefully
take on these big challenges or even
small challenges of kind of like maybe
giving up chocolate sweets and fizzy
drinks like i did so having that ripping
effect on the next generation
really kind of installing them that they
can achieve anything that they want
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news and we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with
former energy secretary ambarad and
majid majeed director of union for
justice also a former mep and mayor of
sheffield so welcome to both of you nice
to see you both
so we now have a pretty clear idea of
what the government will be announcing
tomorrow more offshore wind more solar
more nuclear power and probably more oil
and gas from the north sea so let's find
out uh how our guests respond to that
amber rudd grey caprice moga said this
week that the uk should be exploiting
every last cubic inch of gas from the
north sea is he right
in the short term there's a fair point
to be made that
we certainly don't want to be buying
russian gas for any longer than we have
to so much more sensible to take from
the north sea or from the north sea
basin so in the short term he's right
but we mustn't be deluded into thinking
that oil and gas is the long term answer
in the long term energy security is only
really going to be achieved by having
renewables
majeed what do you think of that is that
right that we need to accept that we
need to rely on fossil fuels in the
short term and possibly
exploit new fields
yeah and to be fair it's also kind of
worth noting that the combined impact of
high inflation and soaring energy bills
means over 34 of the population will
suddenly you know be unable to afford
the cost of living this month alone and
if the energy security strategy is you
know also to deliver security for
families who really can't ignore the
pain that millions of households are
kind of currently facing so so basically
the government really if it really wants
to you know stop importing russian gas
and make sure that everyone can afford
its basic essentials we can of course
mainly need to focus on renewable
energies
but amber rudd
international energy agency the ipcc
have made it absolutely clear there
should be absolutely no new oil and gas
projects what kind of message does it
send out to the big polluters of the
world
if we would go ahead with new projects
like this
well the main thing message we need to
send out is that we're not going to fund
russia's war on ukraine and if we're
still going to use oil and gas we need
to use our own not the stuff that we buy
from russia which helps them pay for
their war so let's get that absolutely
clear from the start and i can't can't
see how anybody really can disagree with
that but at the same time we have to
make sure that we invest in renewables
and can i just pick up on my gt's point
with which i largely agree and this is
why i would hope to see but we don't
know how much support we'll get from
government on demand reduction because
there is a cost of living crisis people
are getting some help with their bills
but frankly at the bottom end not enough
and what we i would love to see is more
emphasis on how we help people use less
which is good for the climate and good
for their purses well yes and majimaji
one way of using less is to improve
insulation in our homes it looks like
we're not going to get any of that
tomorrow the treasury seems to be
worried about the cost of it do you
think that's a mistake
it's a really sad big mistake
unfortunately and we really need to
support household incomes like right now
because you know insulating homes and
building more renewable power will of
course take time but energy bills are
soaring like right now kind of thing so
an energy uplift and so on an emergency
uplift in benefits in line with today's
inflation rate and you know reinstating
that important 20 pound a week uplift to
universal credit could really formulate
the first steps of a living income and a
new social security system that would
really you know make sure that everyone
can afford life's basic essentials but
majid the prime minister said today that
there's a limit to the amount of
taxpayers money that can be used to
address rising energy bills i mean a lot
of money has been spent already and this
is off the back of a pandemic as well do
you have some sympathy there for the
treasury
not really
not really to be fair because even like
i know you briefly touch upon like the
whole aspect of kind of like looking at
different and also like new nuclear for
example right like
yes there is a need for nuclear by the
same time we really can't afford to do
it on the backs of ordinary households
so like listen nuclear power in itself
is ridiculously expensive and unlike
other technologies deploying more
nuclear power has only you know led to
costs going up and we know that
boris and the treasury they're all kind
of massive fans of nuclear power but
this kind of really needs to be coupled
with assurances that further costs
aren't going to be loaded onto bills for
basically low-income households and
that's what people fundamentally care
about
well yeah i mean he's right isn't he um
amber rudd about the extra cost that all
these commitments will make i mean are
you concerned about that is it worth
pushing for nuclear especially given
that it'll take so long for that to come
on stream
well the truth is that renewable energy
is cheaper than oil and gas at the
moment i mean it goes to it's common
sense isn't it that once you've got it
up wind and sun is going to be cheaper
than getting hydrocarbons out of the
ground so if we want to keep costs down
we need to invest in the renewables in
order to deliver that but i'm afraid i
think maggie is going to be disappointed
tomorrow because tomorrow is about when
the date when the government says energy
security they mean making sure we can
keep the lights on on and the government
energy policy is always trying to get
the balance between keeping the lights
on keeping carbon emissions down and
keeping the prices down and last year
was all about carbon emission reduction
and we've got carbon emission
commitments from 80 percent of the world
to get to net zero zero at some stage
and it was you know for a certain extent
it was a really ambitious deal that was
dealt at the end of last year to try and
achieve that but everything has changed
since february the 24th when russia
invaded ukraine what we're talking about
now is hopefully maintaining some of
those reductions but also acknowledging
we need to do more to make ourselves
secure there is no longer a world in
which we are awash with cheap gas that's
over
okay so many different issues for them
to balance it'd be interesting to see
what comes out tomorrow meanwhile today
we've seen huge and coordinated
sanctions against russia by the uk us eu
and nato now the eu in particular is
stopping russian coal and say they're
going to go further in future banning
russian oil and gas now the financial
impact on russia will be huge worth
billions and billions of dollars but for
european countries it's difficult as
well germany and several other countries
have mentioned potential future energy
rationing and what about the climate
impact as well so majeed at germany for
example heavily reliant on russian gas
in particular
is it understandable that they're not
going further with sanctions given that
it's a tough decision to make to be
found it's not only german you've got
bulgaria and so many other kind of
european countries who are really
reliant on and russian gas but the eu as
you can mention is not united on this
with foreign ministers kind of recently
meeting the base weren't able to come to
some sort of agreement but
listen we're at war with russia already
be it a trade one and historically you
know sanctions and high tariffs on
imports and exports have worked towards
and i've worked before but they've
always come at our cost basically that
could be massive there probably will be
massive hikes on energy prices and
russians as you mentioned that germany
are kind of currently kind of exploring
but listen we're all witnessing what's
happening in ukraine at the moment and
we need to establish whether we think
there is a way we can first if there is
a way that we can de-escalate the
situation and give the kremlin maybe a
way to de-escalate which someone might
argue maybe we shouldn't go to this far
with these sanctions or maybe putin is
so hell-bent and can't be stopped which
in that case we need to do everything
that we can to stop him but
fundamentally there is going to be a
cost
okay
and amber rob what are the implications
uh for the climate i mean could it be
that this will accelerate the move
towards renewables or will countries
just replace uh oil and gas by producing
more coal in their own countries is it
good or bad news for the environment
of course that is the worst possible
outcome we could have of all the
different sources of fuel
coal is the very worst and i do worry
that in the short term we may see a
rising coal from eastern european
countries if they stop importing it
importing it from russia and if they
stop getting gas from russia however
let's be optimistic and hope that
instead we get a common sense investment
in renewables and i think germany's um
plan not to turn off their nuclear is a
good plan on that as well and we
actually do achieve more energy security
away from russia but do it in a way that
is clean let's hope we can do that
because it's a great opportunity to do
that okay amber majeed always
interesting to hear your views thanks
very much indeed for joining us this
evening
well on tomorrow's show i'll be joined
by climate justice activist and medical
student michaela loach and leading
expert in carbon footprinting mike
berners-lee that's it for me thanks for
watching i'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you